hello and welcome to this video is that
the right number yes it is playing
almani 1979 and just play the same thing
I did in the game perform broke quite
well
it's remarkable exactly is the same
thing
okay yeah what you mean
give me the bishop pale I rarely say no
to that okay
let's put this annoyed to see form and
then see if I can exploit the dark
squares a little bit he's got pretty big
dark squares
you might just play Quincey eddo
I can I can play to play this right I
don't think black is so keen on playing
be 6cm
hmm
you
yeah I just wondered if this is muth
you make a discovery with Quincy five
and sorry Prince if I was a foreign
takes Knight eggs I mean this is what I
was wondering about
Kim
but what is the catch if I do this
this is Scrooge right
you
you
I would have liked to take on b6 on
Prasad word well
v6 was annoying
yes e6 is also hanging but it is 98 so
let's do this
no I hear my position is of course very
nice and just have to figure out the
best way of continuing Knight b7 is
certainly a move
yeah and this is probably good enough
the rook trade I don't really see black
moving the rook and the 95 will come
just have enormous pressure there okay
man he moves it away but now 95 is just
an absolute absolutely horrific picture
from like you cannot play 97 you cannot
play 95 it's really a bit of a pain so
no they're still not
[Music]
[Music]
you
and that is
and it's possible
you
95 is a bit of a problem
I don't I don't have a good square
against 95
see for cakes
better for me I think but it's not what
I wanted to do
takes rook DC 195 Bishop Tito it doesn't
doesn't really react to my move Bishop
g5 I thought
threat I didn't think that this wasn't
thread
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
Wow
move
[Music]
yeah this is just this completely
winning for watch si impossible that
black stands does you have no squares
it's just it's just not going to work
you
this is a tooth line and he has
absolutely not a single move pawn moves
but he will run out that's funny
it's just not a move available
it's results we will resign known
no smooth NIDA fades okay rook is 7mate
you
this is probably a position where the
engine finds a meat annex
I really don't see how he avoids it
we lose everything
96 is probably the best move relatively
speaking yeah no I think I could let's
see if the engine finds a checkmate it
would be would be there is 71 70 and 80
made in 20
okay that's probably will go down after
a while
made it 12 okay so um let's start so I
got the bishop here and now this it's
interesting to check here look at the 8
I was thinking about Queen d6 here
already and maybe it is better I just
thought after Queen c8 I wasn't quite
certain if I have a good reply I just
saw I just saw if I do this that there
is likely Knight b6 but that might be
wrong oh it is of course well yeah I can
successfully give the Queen this is just
just winning him
yeah I mean okay as far too much became
Bishop III is running it to be five so
it here um Quincy eight has to be played
I'm fairly certain Quincy eight and then
from here we have to check I wasn't
entirely certain what my movers 95 I
think there is 98 this is the thing
tonio night nasty 695 takes takes Bishop
e7
it was the equal interesting
the apron looks very dangerous though
that's something where I wouldn't be
surprised if at some what
the calculation depth what could be
relevant I don't know stuff the same he
has to do this though after him after
this I'm just substantially better
rookie one night be eight night to be
seven yeah somewhere here probably there
is some improvement Bishop c5 is better
okay let's let's have a look though I
probably of course that just wins the
exchange hmm there was silly
yeah I'm just attacking it and of course
rookie 896 is not particularly
sophisticated okay yeah he has spent a
spent a long long time and came up with
c4 i-95 was annoying and I would do
didn't want to play Knight b7 I mean I
was just coming from there huh even
though it made it made some sense yeah
some play to do this but I didn't want
to go back and then when C form it still
should keep some advantage though yeah I
was expecting him to take really take
route to see 195 that was my my line
that I felt would happen something like
like this I was thinking and I should be
better he doesn't have a good discovery
and still the night II is very bad but
that that feels better than the game so
now I could have immediately taken on b5
okay so what is the deal
I simply be should be seven okay that is
not very difficult
plus five is pretty strict yeah okay
well I went with the lame move Bishop f8
before yeah this is a bit too lame but
okay I didn't have so much time so
something simple was kind of welcome
yeah now I mean that doesn't work again
you cannot take him that it's just too
too bad you know we are approaching
pretty awful Terra dream
yeah
Suz one type stuff yeah this is if
you'll give it some time
Justin made in something like has snow
this is a funniest one where I have two
nice chick mates and well there's
nothing else King cannot move rook
cannot move Knight cannot move that's it
okay guys thanks for watching